the argument from ownership this slave
slash baby is my property slash body you
can't tell me what to do with it the
argument from privacy no one is forcing
you to have slaves slash abortions mind
your own business the argument from the
superseding rights my property slash
body rights come before the rights of a
slave fetus the argument from
inevitability slavery abortion has been
around for thousands of years it's never
going away we might as well have a safe
and legal system in place for it the
argument from pseudoscience slave slash
fetuses aren't really people the
argument from socioeconomics if slavery
abortion ends most of these slave slash
babies will end up on the streets the
argument from the court slavery abortion
was vindicated by the supreme court it's
already been decided there's no point in
arguing the argument from faux
compassion
slavery slash abortion is in the best
interest of african slash babies the
world can be a cruel place it's best to
protect them from it by keeping them in
slave slash killing them then there's
the argument from the assumed hypocrisy
of the other side you say you want to
end slavery slash abortion but you don't
want to live with freed black slash
adopt unwanted babies for yourself